over the weekend on saturday president
trump became the first president
ever to go for two two for two in
impeachment acquittal so he's been
impeached twice
it happened basically within the space
of a year and he was
acquitted twice by the senate this time
there were more votes to impeach him or
convict him in the senate than there
were last time around last time it was a
straight party vote with only mitt
romney breaking ranks this time there
were seven republicans
breaking ranks according to abc news
exactly a month and a week
after insurrectionists incited a riot at
the capitol on january 6th
and you gotta love the the loaded
language there from abc news former
president donald trump's second
impeachment trial came to a climactic
end on saturday afternoon with trump
being acquitted for his alleged role in
inciting the deadly event a majority of
senators voted to convict but failed to
reach the super-majority threshold
needed for conviction
trump said in a statement this has been
yet another phase of the greatest witch
hunt in the history of our country
no president has ever gone through
anything like it it continues because
our opponents cannot forget the almost
75 million people the highest number
ever for a sitting president who voted
for us just a few
short months ago he's not totally wrong
about this particular fact the reality
is that since he was elected in 2016
there were many many people who simply
could not accept the fact that trump was
president
and then there were a lot of people who
were so upset that 75 million americans
voted for him
in november that they attempted to
essentially lump in
all of those people with the capital
rioters i've been saying this since the
day it happened it was pretty obvious
that the left-wing and media agenda here
was to lump everybody in together with
the people who committed actual criminal
and evil acts
on january 6. president trump said our
historic patriotic
beautiful movement to make america great
again has only just begun in the months
ahead i have much to share with you i
look forward to continuing our
incredible journey together to achieve
american greatness for all of our people
there has never been
anything like it drama ensued on the
senate floor on saturday morning when
senators voted to hear from witnesses so
here is the reality here
the reality is that democrats made it
kind of easy on republicans
i should be frank about this democrats
blew this one the reason that they blew
this one
is because they recognized a simple
reality the longer this trial
dragged out the more americans were
going to ask a very easy question
why are we doing this like really this
is what always happens with impeachment
at the very beginning there's a fair bit
of support for them and then as they
drag on the polls start to turn against
the party that's doing the impeachment
that is particularly true
when the person they're attempting to
impeach and convict has been out of
office for months
because democrats did not want to call
witnesses they wanted to get this thing
done fast so democrats made two mistakes
here like
very early they made some mistakes one
was they had a snap impeachment in the
house
now the argument for the snap
impeachment in the house was that this
happened on january 6th well impeachment
by january 10th we'll get him out of
there by january 15th
and then we won't have to worry about
the last five days him leading some sort
of insurrection
but here's the thing democrats didn't
believe that because if democrats
had actually believed that then they
would have moved fast in the senate
which they did not
remember nancy pelosi passed the
impeachment in the house with
essentially a straight party line vote
10 republicans voting in favor
and then instead of transmitting the
articles of impeachment to the senate
right away
she waited for like a very long weekend
in order to get it to the senate
and by that point it was basically five
days from the time that trump was to
leave office anyway so that wasn't
enough time for the senate to actually
do its work
so if the idea is we need to get rid of
this guy like asap right now because
he's so dangerous
then she would have transmitted it right
away which was the explanation for of
course why they had a snap impeachment
in the first place
if however the idea here is that you
have to punish a president who's no
longer in office
because we can't let a future president
think he can get away with this sort of
stuff well then he wouldn't have had the
snap impeachment would you
you have had a full-scale investigation
the house would have done its work
it would have taken months they would
have deposed probably hundreds of
witnesses
they would have had to talk to everybody
immediately around trump about his
activities
that day and immediately before and
after they didn't do any of that
so what that meant is that you ended up
with the democrats basically catching
his catch can which suggests that again
their strategy here
was not really to get a conviction their
strategy here was almost entirely about
painting one side of the political aisle
as complicit in january 6th
that's really what this was about
because again if it was about snap
impeachment they would have moved faster
in the first place
and then once they got past trump
leaving office
the rationale for the snap impeachment
was gone because he was out
right now would be the time for the
full-scale investigation
so what could have happened while the
senate could have called witnesses and
this is what it came down to over the
weekend there was this really really
bizarre situation in which democrats
reversed themselves
on witnesses so what happened is that
there was a a republican congressperson
who basically was going to testify that
she had talked to kevin mccarthy
and kevin mccarthy had talked to trump
and kevin mccarthy had told trump to
call off
the dogs and trump didn't call off the
dogs or any of this
and so this came out late on on friday
night early saturday morning
and the democrats in the house then
voted you know what maybe we should call
witnesses
and then the senate democrats voted
maybe we should call witnesses and then
within an
hour they reversed themselves on
saturday morning say you know what
forget it we're not going to call
witnesses let's just let's just take a
vote
according to the washington post the
debate among the house impeachment
managers raged through the night
as the hours and then minutes ticked it
down early saturday before it was widely
expected to be the final day of former
president donald trump's senate trial
after weeks of bending to political
pressure to ensure a speeding proceeding
some on the house team wanted to make
one final furious push to demand a more
intensive investigation
to call witnesses to talk about trump's
behavior before during and after the mob
attack on the capitol on january 6th
right which again that that is a
position that makes sense if you believe
that this was such a grave
evil and injustice on the part of trump
right now not on the part of the writers
on the part of trump
that you required a full-scale 911 style
commission well then you should have
done that
and so how some of the house impeachment
managers were like okay well you know
what
i know we're supposed to vote on this
thing but why don't we go ahead and do
that and senate democrats initially were
like well
okay and then they reverse themselves
according to the washington post should
they seek to call a republican lawmaker
who was willing to talk about her
knowledge
of trump's dismissive comments to the
house gop leader who pled with him
during a riot to call off his supporters
should they call the leader himself
kevin mccarthy what about aids to former
vice president mike pence whose dramatic
of actual
evacuation was caught on security video
played for the first time publicly last
week
any of these moves risked extending the
proceedings for weeks but nonetheless
these potential surprise developments
consumed the managers late into friday
night and in the wee hours on saturday
according to multiple democrats with the
deliberate who are familiar with the
liberations
in the end the managers backed off
allowing the senate vote to take place
as expected but not
before a chaotic back and forth caught
senators off guard sent trump's legal
team into a fury and exposed
long-simmering tensions among democrats
over how aggressively to hold the former
president
accountable the debate over witness
testimony continued to learn large after
the vote
as key questions about trump's actions
and motives remained unanswered see this
was the big problem there were two big
problems with the democrats impeachment
push
one was the actual impeachment charge
which centered around incitement
incitement is very difficult to prove
suggesting that trump quote unquote
incited the riot when he said to
peacefully and patriotically march down
to the capital to show displeasure
that is not a particularly convincing
argument because again incitement is a
pretty high bar
and suggesting that it was incitement to
insurrection is a double high bar
because again you have to show number
one that it was incitement and number
two that trump actually wanted an
insurrection
not just people to go and do something
criminal he wanted an insurrection to
overthrow the united states government
which again there's very little evidence
of so that was problem
number one with all of this the second
problem over all of this
is that many of the accusations that
were being made about trump's behavior
were being made
second or third hand it was unnamed
staffer inside the white house talking
to new york times
and the democrats didn't bother to call
witnesses they just cited the new york
times report
that ain't going to be good enough to
support an impeachment effort the the
democrats
put themselves in a very difficult
position with this impeachment because
they were very inconsistent in their
pursuits
first they said it was a crisis then
they said it was not a crisis
first they said that it was about
incitement for insurrection and then
they said it was about
trump's general activity between
november and january 6th
well they didn't try to bring an
impeachment charge against him in
december and he was saying exactly the
same things in january as he was saying
in december
for example and as it turns out a lot of
the language that they say that trump
was using that was quote unquote
incitement is language that has been
used by democrats over and over
this is the point that trump's team made
on friday when they were closing their
argument they just played tape over and
over of democrats
saying exactly the same kind of stuff
that trump has said and nobody batting
an eye
in the senate democrats are going to
fight like hell to make this
a reality we are going to fight like
hell to protect your vote well i'll tell
you i'm confident that we're going to
fight like hell to make sure they can
we are going to fight like hell to make
sure that everyone who wants to vote can
exercise that right to vote this
election is coming whether the president
wants it or not and we're going to fight
like hell in congress
to make sure that the mail still works
today biden's vp kamala harris
told supporters in a fundraising note
that it is time to quote
fight like hell to protect the supreme
court
okay so the the fact that the trump
impeachment managers the the
defense team that they were saying you
know you guys use this kind of language
all the time and you have no problem
with it
that is accurate i've said all along
there is no neutral standard the
democrats are going to uphold here
in going after trump on the basis of
incitement if they'd gone for a vague
charge i said this early on if they just
want to say abusive power
then it would have given republicans
some wiggle room but at the same time it
would have given them less wiggle room
on the one hand more wiggle room because
abusive power is not an actual legal
charge
on the other hand abuse of power is
probably a more
accurate description of what they think
trump did between november
4th and january 6th in any case here was
trump's lawyer saying you guys keep
saying incitement over and over and over
i'm not sure that that word means what
you think it means
at no point in their presentation did
you hear
the house managers play a single example
of mr trump urging anyone
to engage in violence of any kind
at no point did you hear anything that
could ever possibly be construed as mr
trump
encouraging or sanctioning an
insurrection
senators you did not hear those tapes
because they do not exist
because the act of incitement never
happened
okay meanwhile the democrats are still
trying to make an excuse for why exactly
they didn't call the witnesses because
again if they wanted to show not only
incitement but that there was
action by trump on january 6th to for
example hold up the sending of law
enforcement
well then now would have been the time
jamie raskin was trying to make excuses
for this he's like well you know
but you know what no matter what we said
no matter what we said
republicans would have just voted to
acquit number one that may very well be
true but that's not the point the point
is that if you wanted to actually bring
the strongest possible impeachment
charge
what you actually would have done is you
know the basic research here's jamie
raskin trying to make an excuse
for what was very obviously a
politically moated impeachment
trump knew exactly what they were doing
he knew that that mob which he had
deployed
was there you know occupying people's
offices and threatening
congress so it was there for everybody
to see right so we could have had a
thousand witnesses but that could not
have overcome
the kinds of silly arguments that uh
people like mcconnell
and capita were hanging their hats on
they're trying to have it both ways
okay but here's the problem you still
have to provide the evidence if you
don't provide the evidence you actually
leave republicans with the
perfectly plausible defense you guys
didn't provide the evidence of the chief
charge that you were attempting to make
but again this was all political from
the get-go there were seven republicans
who joined with the democrats to vote in
favor
of the conviction that had been senators
mitt romney of utah
not a surprise susan collins of maine
lisa murkowski of alaska ben sasse of
nebraska bill cassidy of louisiana
richard burr of north carolina and
patumi of pennsylvania
the latter two kind of interesting i
believe both of those guys
are retiring after this particular round
because they don't want to be primary
presumably there's already some talk of
doing that in these particular
home states but it does show that if
you're in a purple state they are less
trumpy in the purple states than they
would be in the non-purple states and
that's something that republicans should
keep in mind
going forward which leads to mitch
mcconnell's response to all of this
so mitch mcconnell did two things one he
voted against the impeachment because he
said listen you can't impeach somebody
who's already out of office
right otherwise you could just impeach
private individuals that's not what this
is really for
but he also slammed trump in pretty
personal terms it's pretty obvious that
mcconnell and many in the republican
higher echelon would like to separate
off from trump at this point you know
thanks for all the cheese but
we're done at this point here's mitch
mcconnell going after trump while
simultaneously not voting for his
impeachment
they did this because they'd been
fed wild falsehoods
by the most powerful man on earth
because he was angry he lost an election
former president trump's actions
preceded
the riot or a disgraceful
disgraceful dear election
of duty okay so that is an argument
that's been made by a lot of republicans
is that trump's behavior
here was really really bad but what this
is really about for mcconnell and for a
lot of republicans is minimizing trump's
influence going forward
on the party and you can see why the
reality is that politically speaking
trump underperformed nearly every
republican across the country in 2020.
i know that that is counter to the sort
of prevailing view among republicans
which is that trump
boosted turnout on the right side of the
aisle he did boost some turnout on the
right side of the aisle but not for him
right he boosted turnout on the right
side of the aisle but he also boosted
turnout on the left side of the aisle
which is why joe biden
a dead candidate a person who has not
been living for several years ended up
winning 80 million votes in the popular
vote
so you can see why mcconnell is doing
what he's attempting to do here
which is i'm not going to separate off
from the party i understand that people
are using the impeachment
as a litmus test of loyalty to the
republican party i'm not going to
vote against that at the same time trump
should not be a key figure going forward
that's mcconnell's attempt meanwhile the
democrats are attempting
pretty strongly to tie all republicans
to trump's
knee here here's nancy pelosi suggesting
that every republican is complicit in
january 6
not just trump every single republican
who didn't vote in favor of impeachment
that was always the goal here right the
goal here was was never that they were
actually going to
get a conviction of trump or even that
they were going to do the the leg work
necessary
to support an impeachment of trump
instead it was really about how can we
best politically lump in everybody all
together really quickly and then move on
with our lives
mike pence hang mike pence
was the chant and they just dismissed
that why because maybe they can't get
another
job what is so important about any one
of us
what is so important about the political
survival of
any one of us that is more important
than our constitution that we take an
oath to protect and defend okay let me
just say this about political leaders
when political leaders grandstand this
way you should never believe them
because political leaders
are are not meant to be moral leaders
they're just not as
we're getting to the portion of the
bible in in judaism every week we read a
different portion of the bible we're
getting the portion of the bible
at this point where the jews build the
golden calf it's right after they
receive
the torah they receive the old testament
and then moses goes back up the mountain
and they get they freak out and they
build a golden calf and the question is
why do they build a golden calf what's
so special about a golden calf
and the reason that they build a golden
calf is because they want something that
is going to lead them but also be a
reflection of them
right something in which they had a part
right it says in the bible that all of
the israelites
all the jews they take out their nose
rings and their earrings and they melt
and they melt them down and they make
this god right then they're gonna
worship that god they worship the god
the neon god that they'd made right
this is what we do with our politicians
we elect these schmucks
i guess it's our fault and then we look
to them and we say why can't they lead
us
well they can't lead you because they're
reflections of you they're not going to
tell you things you don't want to hear
their literal job is to tell you things
that you want to hear this is what
politicians do for a living so nancy
pelosi stands there and she says things
like
why do these politicians why do they
think that that their
own job is so much more important than
this institution yeah nancy
i'm sure that that consideration has
never crossed your mind under any
circumstances but but here's the reality
when it comes to pelosi and the
democrats and this impeachment
it was perfectly obvious what this was
from the beginning as soon as january
6th happened they saw it not as a
tragedy but as an opportunity for the
most part
it was both it was both for them it can
be both right it can be tragedy it can
be a criminal act
it can also be an opportunity
politically for them to ram down their
entire agenda
which is why they rushed this thing that
they've openly said this by the way
is that joe biden's agenda is more
important than taking their time with
the impeachment to determine whether
trump is actually guilty and convictable
what this was really about is making the
political point and then using that as
fuel
to push forward joe biden's ridiculous
agenda and his agenda is ridiculous
joe biden himself put out a statement he
says it was nearly two weeks ago that
jill and i paid our respects to capital
police officer brian siknik who laid in
honor in the rotunda after losing his
life protecting the capital from a
riotous violent mob
on january 6 2021 by the way we're still
finding out some of the details as to
what exactly happened with officers dick
nick the original reports that he was
hit in the head with a fire extinguisher
apparently are untrue that doesn't mean
he didn't die in defense of the capital
we just don't know
really much what happened at this point
biden said today
57 senators including a record seven
republicans voted to find former
president trump guilty of inciting that
deadly insurrection on our very
democracy
this senate vote followed the bipartisan
vote to impeach him by the house of
representatives
while the final vote did not lead to a
conviction the substance of the charge
is not in dispute
even those opposed to the conviction
like senate minority leader mcconnell
believed trump was guilty of a
quote-unquote
disgraceful dear election of duty and
practically and morally responsible
for provoking the violence unleashed on
the capital
okay well this would be the time
presumably for if that's true
right if if that's what he believes that
it's not in dispute now would be a good
time to
recognize that everybody's on the same
side right but um that's not
what's going to happen here right so
biden says this is that
we have to realize that we all have a
duty and responsibility as americans to
defend the truth and defeat the lies
that's how we end this uncivil war
okay and the very first move the left
makes immediately is oh yeah and by the
way you need to
agree with all of the elements of our
agenda so charles blow over at the new
york times symbolizing
this point of view he says blue lives
matter is over
weird um i i noticed that you weren't a
big supporter of blue lives matter for
like this entire time
that in fact if you said blue lives
matter then charles blue got very very
upset with you because he was saying
that that is some sort of denigration of
the idea that black lives matter if you
suggest the police lives matter
but now he says blue lives matter is
over blue lives matter is over because
there are people who didn't vote in
favor
of convicting president trump in the
senate which means they don't care about
cops
now that argument could very well be
extended to black lives matter which
obviously does not give
two craps about the vast number of black
people who are being killed by other
black people in the united states this
is a point that has been
very well made by a bunch of advocates
for civil rights who happen to be on the
right side of the aisle
which is that black lives matter if it
wanted to be taken seriously maybe they
ought to worry about things like the
vast number of young black men who are
being killed by young black men in
cities that actually lack a police
presence
but charles blow would never say that
black lives matter doesn't care about
black lives
because of their absolute willingness to
to ignore
the risk to young black life in removing
the police but here he is saying blue
lives matter it doesn't matter to all
republicans because they didn't vote in
favor of conviction this is
all about the politics and democrats
never played it any other way
there was no point at which they said
that this was about a higher principle
or which they plausibly said that anyway
it was never about a higher principle
that was obvious from their conduct it
was obvious from how they laid out the
charge and it was perfectly obvious
from everything up to including the very
last day of this impeachment when they
could have called witnesses and decided
not to
out of political expedience one of the
democrats even admitting we just wanted
to get home for the weekend
yeah that sounds like principle to me
nancy pelosi i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content